les verts européens en congrès à paris
durant tout ce week end les verts et qui
vivent un tournant politique important
puisqu'ils sont désormais au
gouvernement dans quatre pays du vieux
continent et sur cette lancée ils
partent en campagne pour les européennes
avec un programme commun dans les 15
pays
catherine de mangin myriam métaoui ils
sont grünen joan verdu vers un milliers
d'écologistes venus de toute l'europe
imposerait pour lancer la campagne des
européennes et faire une démonstration
de fortes
il y a dix ans les verts n'existait pour
ainsi dire soir aujourd'hui ils ont des
ministres dans quatre gouvernements sur
15 et espère encore progresser même si
le recul de leurs amis allemands sur le
nucléaire
un peu entamé les enthousiasmes suis
convaincu qu'ils ont fait des erreurs de
communication et d erreur stratégique en
voulant aller trop vite comme maintenant
ils ont ils ont subi un contrecoup
personnellement je crois que c'est un
contrecoup temporaire mais c'est un fait
que ça ne l'a pas fait de bien
il y à un certain nombre de hauts et de
bas on voit que après l'excellent accord
vers français ps français des choix nous
on va si vite on voit qu après
l'excellente accord grünen et spd les
choses on va si vite
on voit aussi qu'à ce niveau là c'est ce
qui fait bouger les choses c'est ce qui
fait avancer la société
honneur à dominique voynet pour ouvrir
ce qu'on dresse les ministres allemands
eux ont pris du retard
la ministre française a souligné la
solidarité entre les coalitions
socialiste vert pour pouvoir en europe
ce qui ne règle pas tous les problèmes
exemple le bras de fer franco allemand
sur la politique agricole commune
une négociation difficile se déroule en
ce moment même à bruxelles je constate
au passage que les égoïsmes nationaux
dans sont pas absents j'espère que les
fonds destinés à la solidarité entre les
régions qui sont absolument nécessaires
mais qui ne font pas descendre de
manifestants dans la rue en général n'en
sortiront pas trop affaiblie
un sujet de satisfaction tout cas pour
dominique voynet l'adoption par les vers
d'un manifeste commun pour les élections
européennes avec toujours au coeur de ce
programme et malgré les difficultés la
sortie du nucléaire
le gouvernement se félicite